hello freak [ __ ] you contacted us
after the Leah Remini interview right
and you wanted to get on and you have
this book that you wrote called ruthless
with the correct pronunciation it's
cabbage miss Carol Miscavige miss Cathy
yeah the actual name of the book is
rootless right Scientology my son David
Miscavige and me right now let me let me
just say this before we get started
because Scientology this is the first
time I've ever been contacted
they sent a an email to my publicist and
they have a rebuttal to what you wrote
and their rebuttal is at a website Ron
Miscavige book calm and they want people
to know about their website which is
Scientology org and they have a
statement this is their statement Ron
Miscavige is seeking to make money on
the name of his famous on David
Miscavige Oh
David Miscavige is taking care of his
father throughout his life both
financially and by helping him and even
the most dire circumstances Rahm
Miscavige was nowhere around when David
Miscavige ascended to the leadership of
the Church of Scientology mentioned by
and working directly with the religions
founder l ron Hubbard and entrusted by
him with the future of the church any
father exploiting his son in this manner
is a sad exercise of betrayal mr. David
Miscavige is far-reaching vision and
unrelenting dedication has brought the
Church of Scientology to where it is
today guaranteeing its future for
generations to come
Scientologist worldwide love and respect
mr. Miscavige for his tireless work on
behalf of their religion so that's
that's their statement that's what they
wanted to say and I feel like it's only
fair you know we had Leah Remini on and
we have you on and I've had Louis tharu
on right and look I feel like I don't
know the story but anytime a father is
so disconnected from his
they have to write a book about them
it's a sad time do you feel like that no
you don't feel sad at all I don't feel
that I just woke up one day and said I'd
like to write a book about Scientology
right and if I can give you a short
encapsulated statement I think we could
set a nice groundwork for the whole
interview you mind if I do that sure
okay I was a Scientologist for 42 years
were you raised in it no I got my family
in in 1970 but I was in the church for
42 years the last 26 and a half years I
worked at the International base in
Hemet California I escaped from that
base on March 25th 2012 you escaped
escaped that's right I had to plan that
escape for six months we can go into
this in more detail but just let me give
you this short story about a year and a
half later there was a private and guest
investigator caught by the name of Duane
Powell who was around the corner from my
house looking at a house to buy so he
could spy on me from that house and
there's no [ __ ] so a lady in the
neighborhood saw him and she thought he
was a drug dealer or up to no good so
she called the West Allis police and
Nick pie came out and confronted the guy
he gave Nick some [ __ ] and Nick said hey
listen man you're under arrest
do you mind if I look in your car so
Nick went to the van and opened it up in
a trunk there were five license plates
from five different states there were
two handguns a stun gun
two rifles one fitted up with the
silencer and 2,000 rounds of ammunition
so they arrested the guy they took him
in for interrogation and then his son
came looking for him because his son was
a partner in this business the father's
name was Dwayne Powell and the son was
Daniel Powell Daniel came looking for
his father and by the way if you want to
hear these interviews they're on Tony
Ortegas website Tony Ortega the
underground bunker you can hear what I'm
telling you okay so Daniel is telling me
you know how they operated they were
getting paid $10,000 a week to follow me
and report on my doings from 8 o'clock
in the morning till 8 o'clock every
night an incident happened in Janesville
Wisconsin what do you do like what could
you possibly do that be worth studying
is it just to freak you out like that's
what I don't understand like if you
follow like if I follow Jamie you know
what you know what I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get Jamie looking at the Internet
Jamie watch a basketball maybe Jamie
goes to gym maybe Jamie goes for a run
yeah Jamie goes on tinder just a little
right right swiping right yeah okay you
could Det out of watching them it's not
like you're out there burying bodies no
kidding anyway let's let me continue it
just goes on so they're interrogating
them that's Nick pie and there was
alcohol Tobacco and Firearms Agent Rick
Lincoln's right and because they were
concerned about that soldier hey maybe
they're out to hit me right because I am
the father of the chairman of the board
right so then Daniel the son is being
interrogated and he said they they
followed me to a town called Janesville
Wisconsin where I went shopping and
alby's grocery store this is this is
very detailed tell me what happened so I
come out and I had bags of grocery and
it was a summer time so I had a puck a
t-shirt on I bent over to put the
groceries in the car I thought my
cellphone was gonna fall out I grabbed
my left chest they're looking at me in
the van which they had been following me
and they saw me the father called his
contact and said listen it looks like
the target is having a heart attack what
should we do they referred to me as the
target oh Jesus no [ __ ] now get a
silencer and [ __ ] 2,000 rounds of
ammo all right okay so they called the
guy Greg said listen let me call you
back
couple minutes later a guy come on the
phone identified himself as David
Miscavige and he said to them listen if
it's his time to die let him die don't
do anything don't intervene that's my
son hmm all right well it didn't just
happen right I mean he didn't you didn't
I won't only interrupt historic yeah I
feel like it goes on but I mean your
relationship with your son didn't just
start there so it had it had to go sour
no [ __ ] right listen my relationship
with David when he was a kid
was incredible I mean we got along great
he was a snappy little kid he was just
very bright great sense of humor just I
enjoyed his company but as he grew older
as he got into Scientology which I got
him in by the way and I can get into
that how I got him in he then started
acquiring power and I think he went from
dr. Jekyll into mr. Hyde
[Applause]
[Music]